i don't like trash and fellow comedians
i really don't i genuinely genuinely
don't no did that change after mencia
you felt a little bit 100 percent really
you felt bad during the moment of it um
uh i realized how much negativity it
creates i was almost looking at like
like if it was a system
right if you're looking at a system
you're looking at like you input
x and you get back this
and i'm like okay a good thing was done
where where people weren't in danger of
having their intellectual property
taken by someone who's far more
successful
but
the weird thing was the anger like
watching the anger like
it's like you're throwing meat to a a
group of [ __ ] piranhas like there's
just this buzzing of people joining on
one side or the other side and i
realized like a lot of this is not
logical and it's one of the problems
with the way human beings interact with
each other that we just choose teams
and it's like a normal natural
inclination that we can't escape no
matter how logical you are like even if
you're like a
super logical person you're still
there's some part of you that has an
inclination towards teams so how do you
push yourself away from it just kind of
recognize what it is like know when it
pops up and just go
this is a dumb road but but is that
tough for you like like when you get
[ __ ] on by one side specifically and
then the other side is like yo you're
pretty cool
how hard is it for you to just stay even
it's okay
like i would [ __ ] on me
for sure wait really if i didn't know me
yeah
for what exactly some other comic i
would make fun of me totally what would
you say oh i'd say terrible things about
steroid use
insecurities being short i have a lot of
great jokes about me really a lot of fun
so you don't even when people make fun
of you do you care well you can care but
it's not going to change the way they
think
like like it's not good if you hear it
like if someone said it to my face like
that's mean yeah like why are you being
mean to me man i don't even know you
yeah people will say mean things to you
just to try to get a reaction out of you
but those people are usually way more
dangerous than the average person that
says something online
the average person says something online
it's like you're not even connected like
maybe you are it's like you're like
you're you're trapped in a
cave and there's like a tunnel that goes
up to the air and you're like [ __ ] you
yeah you're not connected to that person
you're not in front of them if someone
is mean to you in front of you that's a
real problem yeah and weirdness is when
it spills over when people get used to
communicating with people the way they
do on the internet and they try to do it
in real life and you see it all the time
in world star videos
they just get [ __ ] up because they
think they can talk [ __ ] like they talk
[ __ ] on the internet they think they can
just get away with it like they don't
have the same amount if you're if you're
24 and you lived in 1976 or if you're 24
and you live now you got a totally
different type of interaction with
people yeah these [ __ ] people are
interacting with people in a text form
sixty percent of the time yeah so if
that's a part of your development and
everybody agrees i i i agree that people
who grow up in sort of like touch and go
environments they're a little slicker
right we call it street smarts people
like if you don't have any of that
forget it it's over you're fine
and if all you're doing is texting
you're not experiencing life you're
trapped in your house you're trying to
disconnect you're sitting on the couch
getting a [ __ ] neck cramp because
you're [ __ ] texting yeah yeah that's
the people of today yeah that's what's
weird about it yeah you're not designed
for that right so the human brain has to
find a way to catch up so let me tie
this back to what we talked about seeing
all the hate etc what happened to mencio
what would you do differently about
nothing
that's what i was thinking i wouldn't do
a thing different i took the hit but
it's like the hit wasn't it wasn't bad
because i was right and eventually i
knew they would realize i was right and
i would wish that he would realize that
i was right and well the hate i also
people don't realize you took a hit i
think a lot of people's
history of you is yes you call down
mincey and then you had the biggest
podcast on the planet that's true also
yeah they don't know what you went
through afterwards it wasn't bad it was
not bad bad things happen for comics
standards i think it is well i got
banned from the comedy store that was a
that was a real problem because it
wasn't mitzi shore's idea the real
problem was i was on the phone with
mitzi uh like
more than an hour before they called me
to tell me i was banned so i was on the
phone with mitzi and i told her out of
respect what had happened i said mitzi i
go we are [ __ ] tired of this guy
stealing jokes like carlos ah
are you sure he's stealing or missing we
have videos of it he's a [ __ ] thief
and so we we had this conversation on
the phone and she goes well just keep
away from him so i told her that we're
going to release this video she goes
well just keep away from i go i'll do
whatever you want me to do and she goes
okay you want to go up tonight and i
said sure what time do you want to put
me up
she was all 10 30. i code thank you very
much i love you
that's the last time i talked to her
well
then i got a call an hour later and i
realized like she was in a state where
uh
bitsy shores like legitimately
if you looked at all of the people that
are important in the development of
comedy she's the number one most
important person that wasn't a comic
well number one wait why why why did she
short the show she left the comedy store
owned the comedy store oh i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry mitzi shore is paulie
shore's mom uh she's like
she
she uh started the comedy store with her
husband they got divorced she got the
comedy store
and she ran the comedy store in a way
where like she was a strong lady
and she had [ __ ] strong ideas about
what was good what was bad and she would
tell you right to your face
she would tell you i [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] did she ever say that to you [ __ ]
yes what's she saying i had this bit
about and nicole smith and her husband
she [ __ ] hated that bit because she
jay howard marshall that dude who was
like yeah i'm 50 years old yeah by the
way
he was older than bite and he was biting
his dad
but but um she was
responsible for the environment of the
comedy store where she just let the
comedians
express themselves
the best way that they could and and
give them a home and and and set these
standards like [ __ ] standards the
comedy store prior yeah uh kennedy
bill hicks bill so many legends david
letterman worked out there yeah eddie
griffin you know damon wayans was there
a lot martin lawrence was there a lot it
was like dice clay
like so many people came out of that
place and it was chaos it didn't always
work out perfectly but
she designed it in a way
where she could create a place where
these really [ __ ] up people could come
and perform and she would call it her
island and misfit toys
she knew what she was doing man
and you know
you know she's a
completely unusual person why
there's nobody very few people just
dedicate themselves to a thing like that
and like have this idea of like what's
the right way to do it and they're right
she was right
she was right so often yeah like someone
would call and complain about kennison
and she would i know
she said
the place was packed every night she did
not give a [ __ ] but how is she okay with
mencia then because this is why she
didn't she didn't know and i also think
she was having some legitimate health
problems unfortunately yeah when i first
met her she was already in 94 she was
already struggling a little and then as
time went on it got worse and i don't
think if people don't come to her and
complain
i don't think she necessarily knows
unless she's watching every single set
who came up with this bit first
she doesn't know right so if you just
come down for one 20-minute set and you
see someone kill
and you go oh my god he's hilarious
if you had come 20 minutes before
you might have saw paul mooney do his
version of right right and if that was
the case maybe then she would be able to
go hey what the [ __ ] but
like i said then even in the 90s she was
already struggling you know she had a i
think it was a neurological disorder
and um it was hard for her so i don't
blame her but she had ideas that didn't
necessarily work but you [ __ ] never
know what's going to work how many
people did we started out with that were
like open micros that you think about
that i think about that newer you knew
they were yeah yeah
and they just [ __ ] they fell apart on
re-entertaining yeah yeah
yeah yeah think about that like the
first friend i knew that there was a
comic that stopped
and they were funny too uh-huh but they
just didn't want to go through it
there's a girl that i dated
when i was 21 as a girl i dated when we
were both open micros together she was
funnier than me like she was so funny
she was hilarious she was [ __ ]
hilarious and i remember thinking
if i don't make it as a comedian at
least i [ __ ] her
this lady's the next roseanne
like she's so good
she was a killer and then what happened
i don't know stopped it i don't know i
don't know i lost track i'm experienced
we lost touch with her
friends but i want to know her name yeah
i moved to new york and what i don't
want to say it and when i moved to new
york
it just stopped yeah
i mean back then you had so few
opportunities and if you didn't get one
i imagine would just wear you down
because you're just toiling at that
point yeah like this internet [ __ ] is so
different it's so different well i've
been through both things yeah and uh the
what what it really makes me
understand like more than anything is
like how important it is to like share
share success
and like get everybody out of that
horrible period in the beginning where
you don't know if you're going to make
it because the more people that you can
get that are convinced that they could
be professionals yeah the more you're
gonna get those dudes that we remember
from the open mic days that didn't make
it i think about that girl all the time
i think about her she was [ __ ] funny
man she was funny she had a witty way of
looking at things yeah and i'm like she
was 21. we were both 21. i'm like what
would happen to her when she was 29 what
about when she's 33 she might be a
murderer right now she might be
straightening up slaying on netflix yeah
selling out arenas just walking out
there
yeah
she was that good but for whatever
reason
there's not there's no you know back
then it was dog eat dog and everybody
thought they were going to be the host
of the tonight show well there was two
shows yeah and then maybe you get a half
hour and then there was a sitcom game
yeah sitcom game when uh tim allen got
his show and roseanne got her show and
seinfeld and brett butler then the whole
game became get a deal to do
yeah and craft of an act about this it
seems like a pilot yeah like you would
he would do an act that was like a pilot
for a sitcom and we all got intoxicated
by the sitcom world yeah guys that clip
was brought to you by blue chew best
boners in the business same active
ingredients as cialis or viagra but this
is the true the only one we rock with
get yours for free at bluetooth.com
promo code andrew all you gotta do is
pay five dollars shipping